right now the city of Henderson hosting
a fentanyl awareness Summit at the
College of Southern Nevada so this is an
effort to bring law enforcement public
officials and health authorities all
together to talk about this growing
problem 8 news now reporter Brian will
explains the dangers and what this
Summit hopes to accomplish
and there could be an offense in this
little half a pill to kill you Keith
Carter combats drug trafficking here in
Nevada and hasn't seen a drug crisis
like this in all his time in law
enforcement so what we see today is a
variety of pills powders that are
manufactured in clandestine Labs there's
no quality control there's no testing
there's no assurance that everything is
right it's alarming here in Clark County
with a 620 percent increase in fentanyl
related overdose deaths among residents
here in Clark County just within the
last decade and the CDC says overdose
deaths are the number one killer of
people ages 18 to 45. if you think your
child is safe from from fentanyl they're
not and we need to make them aware of
the the urgency in which we need to
address this issue Henderson mayor
Michelle Romero wants parents to take
this warning right to their kids at this
Summit the city of Henderson launched a
new anti-drug campaign last year eight
children died from fentanyl related
overdoses here in Clark County we're
having kids that are overdosing we're
having kids that are dying and we can't
have that that's not acceptable in this
community and we want to make sure that
we prevent that to the greatest extent
we can